[Musique]
malgré la guerre le cren prévoit de
récolter cette année 50 millions de
tonnes de céréales
pourtant ces silos à grains stocks
encore les récoltes de l'année dernière
il ne reste que trois semaines avant la
nouvelle récolte et pourtant certains de
nos silos sont complètement place
il ya plus ou moins 7000 tonnes dans
celui ci
soit l'équivalent de deux trains
et le chargement prend du temps
nous allons donc devoir trouver d'autres
solutions de stockage
le réseau ferroviaire européen n'a pas
été conçu pour acheminer hors du pays
les produits agricoles ukrainien sa
capacité est limitée
victor discutent des alternatives
possibles avec l'un des gérants tant que
nous avons un peu changé notre stratégie
de vente avant je cherchais un acheteur
puis je m'occupais de la logistique
maintenant nous confirmons d'abord le
transport puis nous cherchons un
acheteur non mais regardez j'ai ces
contrats ça ce sont les volumes
le lendemain 5 camions arrivent
ils ne pourront transporter que 25
tonnes chacun une infime partie du stock
pour exporter toutes les céréales
actuellement entreposées en ukraine il
faudrait 1 millions de ses véhicules
longtemps je vais m'en prendre au sort
nous en voyons actuellement quelques
chargement par camion à la frontière
terrestre d'une crème
normalement en temps de paix tous
devraient être acheminés par train et
directement vers les ports maritimes
mais les ports maritimes ukrainiens sont
soient occupés soit bloquée par la
russie
des dizaines de cargos sont immobilisés
depuis février
sur ce navire il ya vingt-huit mille
tonnes de maïs et il ya huit navires de
ce type pleinement chargée qui reste
bloqué sur ce port le maïs peut pourrir
s'il reste là
l'armée craint des attaques ciblant les
ports et nous demandent de ne montrer
aucun indice permettant de les
identifier
l'activité y est pourtant faible seuls
de rares camions viennent parfois
emporter une cargaison
officiellement les portes ne sont pas
fermées mais ils ne sont pas sûrs
dissoudre depuis le début de l'invasion
dix navires ont été la cible de tirs y
compris des navires immatriculés à
l'étranger un citoyen du bangladesh a
été tué il était membre de l'équipage de
l'un d'eux les porcs sont donc
physiquement bloqués comment pouvez vous
naviguez si vous risquez de vous faire
tirer dessus qui prendrait un tel risque
quelques bateaux naviguent encore tout
de même dans les eaux ukrainiennes sur
le danube
4 millions de tonnes de céréales ont pu
quitter le pays par cette voie pour des
raisons de sécurité il est interdit de
filmer les ports fluviaux de renier
ismail aujourd'hui très actif
les navires viennent de souligner
roumanie soit ils remontent directement
vers les ports ukrainiens soit il
récupère des cargaisons dont les ports
roumains de galati braila avant de
repartir
le jour de notre visite les péniches
ukrainienne attendue après la n'était
pas arrivé
là où il ya des grains il y à des
pigeons
les bases sont souvent très en retard
car elle pas 6 à 8 heures à la douane
pour nos buteurs c'est beaucoup car nous
pourrions chargé deux ou trois barges
dans ce laps de temps
la promesse de l'ue est de simplifier
les formalités n'essaie pas encore
concrétisé quand je n'ai rien vu de
concret bien sûr nous voulons que tout
soit fait correctement mais il faudrait
accélérer la procédure les papiers
doivent être offerts la marchandise doit
être contrôlée mais plus rapidement et
future marpa la bureaucratie n'est pas
le seul problème
le sietom gorgui à khost enfin à
souligner nous avons attendu dix neuf
jours pour entrer dans le port
demain nous partons en ukraine pour
faire le plein de serial
les retards sont en partie due à la
pénurie de pilotes de porc
nous devons parfois rentrer chez nous et
dormir changer de vêtements nous ne
pouvons pas travailler en continu
et surtout pas la nuit parce que ces
navires sont assez vieux ils ne sont pas
bien équipés
[Musique]
selon lui la formation de pilotes
supplémentaires prendrait six mois
ce navire et deux autres passeront la
nuit ici
c'est bon de pouvoir enfin se reposer
une fois nous avons attendu deux
semaines une autre fois une semaine
aucune routine est un les
roumains n'ont pas la capacité
suffisante
il faudrait de plus gros navires la
seule solution est de mettre fin à la
guerre nous allons gagner la guerre et
tout le monde aura ses céréales quant au
port seront ouvertes ou partira de là et
tout fonctionnera bien
un grand bonjour à mâcon de notre part
dites lui d'envoyer des chars
pendant ce temps au large des côtes
roumaine une centaine de navires
attendent de pouvoir accéder au danube